I used to go on stage like I have a bad
knee and like I would go on stage with
the Canes and I was like I wonder if
this'll like give me that pity laugh hey
look at that guy in a hobble up there
you know but then like the next day the
weather would change on my knee would
feel okay so I couldn't wear it I'll do
it all the time
yeah I feel really bad if I was like ya
know sometimes I need the king yeah
maybe something like that maybe a neck
brace
[Music]
holidays are a lot of work let's not
listen to dance around it I mean that's
why these ecards are the way we just
email someone like you just said like
Happy Holidays but no it has to be some
elaborate code that you have to enter -
you know identity questions Santa I mean
it's really not it's a lot of work for
nothing but I used to love those ecards
when they first came on the scene in
like 1998 bluemountain I say you can
make it your own like more of an erotic
thing than usual yeah I don't know I'm
not really big on the web but let's go
around the room here who's local who's
New York gridlock gridlock in effect
coming up Jenn's local yes Jen I'm in
New Jersey there you go I consider that
local yeah so I seem to go to Asbury
Park or what would your what would your
Christmas be uh well I stay like in
Somerset by New Brunswick yourself to a
night at the stress factory yes yes come
early cos the buffet they started at
6:00 David what do you what's what's
your holiday place well I already passed
thanks Nicky Bobby there's an elaborate
Christmas tree and very tasteful yet
practical menorah it was over about
4,000 years ago it definitely never
really got the same
I don't really celebrate the holidays of
course New Year's I work on New Year's
do you work on New Year's
yeah yeah it's Sarah you work in yours
no see Margo price who's that some
country singer
oh nice where somewhere in Brooklyn I
forgot Joe got the tickets well that's
cool yeah I wish I could just I don't
know I always get scared that I work all
the time cuz I'm scared I'll have no fun
plans
so that's the thing you get out do you
get that moment of loneliness where you
just did the show and then it's the
countdown and then everyone's kissing
and hugging you're just standing there
talking to the to the numbers that's the
worst is when you do a whole show and
then your show ends in a like 11:48 and
then the mcs to go back out I've done
this a lot to do the countdown yes well
I come back out on stage like the emcee
comes back on does some buffer time I
don't ever know why I can't just end it
and do the countdown and they don't say
goodnight but yeah so awkward and then
every like you said everyone's kissing
everyone's celebrating and I'm like
hugging the emcee is the portrait of a
comedian right there like that's the
best like I don't think I've ever kissed
someone on New Year's Eve how about this
they pay you extra to do the countdown
like that's like a negotiation thing
like I won't do the entire countdown
I'll come hard five four three two one
you can let the opener like kind of get
it going you know I also do it in I do
countdowns around the world I like to
watch as New Year's Eve around in their
language but yeah that's a tough night
I'd say that's the worst night to be a
comic is New Year's Eve that's the worst
one the second one would be Thanksgiving
Halloween yeah but that's like some
places it's a party some places it's a
train wreck but it's it's usually like
no one expects that much on Halloween
why thanks cuz there's all families
there and it's always that weird like
you know it's like you know you're like
they'll always tell you like there's a
lot of kids home from college so it's
gonna be a while shell but it really
just turns out to be like you know
people bringing their old relatives out
because they have
nothing to do with them we all agree on
that winner yeah no that's a good point
I guess I don't really work that often
on Thanksgiving but even just the days
around it it's that's traveler vibe
playing it's all kids from back home
they're all drunk and it's usually just
families yeah I what do you do I have
wait are more dates Pearl Harbor 7th is
not that good from Harvard a it's it's a
touch and go kind of way Valentine's Day
look yeah that's that's another one
where you just yeah lonely and like what
am i doing and they don't even want to
really be in it it's not like a good
it's not necessarily good there's not
first dates there but there are I don't
know is that a really romantic night out
really understood that like you know
it's like we love each other now let's
go watch you know a comic comedy always
perplexed why people bring first dates
to comedy shows because I although it's
what I do for a living and I think it's
a great form of entertainment it's
awkward for it can be awkward for a
first year it brings up subjects that
you just don't want to get into yet you
don't feel comfortable like even me I
would not feel uncomfortable laughing at
certain things next to a boy I might be
trying to impress really you're like you
know if it's something gross or
something I'll set something on stage
it's really discussing about
her pants and I relate to it and I
laughed and his guy is thinking about me
my pants and that's just not
something I want to have on a first date
yeah but he probably he's also run his
best behavior so he's probably you know
like waiting to see a few laughs of it
and then he'll laugh at so like you
won't be he's a creep bring that energy
into a first date of having to eat so
what's the alternative what are you
thinking trap room or make your own pick
your own adventure those escape rooms I
can't think of anything worse well I I
really love that you came on
bumping mics and I it was so cool to see
you in LA I grilled her about like
living in LA because you lived there for
a while yeah yeah and I thought it would
be like a wild party but it's like
stressful you know it was it's a lot of
did you guys ever live in a LA or
anything no no did you serve no it for
years okay and how was your experience I
just I was an alcoholic that whole year
I told Dave do you think it's like have
you ever like you know like there's one
thing like moving to LA like with all
the hope and promise
LA I think people should make more of
that be able to do a rant at the airport
[Music]
like tape and exit video like you're
leaving big brothers that's a good idea
we excited to get out or were you I've
been back twice I've moved initially I
moved there right out of college no
money and I was babysitting and temping
and then I got on The Tonight Show and I
felt after three years of being there I
was on The Tonight Show and I thought
everything would change and I was still
broke nothing changed and then two
months later I had to move back home to
st. Louis to live with my parents and
then I moved back there when I had a TV
show so I'd it was a different
experience and I was sober but when I
was living there initially I mean I was
drinking so much every night and I was
driving home from I was flirting with a
DUI that's how I why I really had to get
out of town I did not have $10,000 to
get a DUI I was driving buzzed one block
home from residuals the bar in the
valley where you can go and bring a
residual check under $1 yeah and but it
was just I'm so lucky I got out of that
town without a DUI because that was just
that was in the the works for me I think
that's good that you got out of there
New Yorkers are more drinking friendly
town yeah oh my god it was amazing to
come here you have a drink for a while
though right no decades I was wondering
like why you picked to come back East
instead of like going like you know what
I'm in LA already let's give Hawaii a
shot it's good morning Maui you could
have been like the host of that show for
a while and I like worked your way onto
the
magnum p.i there's a lot of like shows
out there dude NCI yes Pearl Harbour you
imagine the people who like we're on
like the TV shows there and they like
just like hanging out like waiting for
the next one what do you mean like the
the shows that just y-yeah like los
exactly using to be out there well then
you like to be out there shooting of
show to live in Hawaii Mike you would
like that I would love to get on a show
and go be forced to live in Vancouver or
Denver or a beach person
I would never even go out in the Sun but
I just I want to be I want the
opportunity to live other places than
New York or LA just for a couple months
and would you do that sure I haven't
been there what's your take on it I was
there years ago I think it's more of a a
Hollywood England now than it was when I
was there you know now it's like you
know they're like well everybody there
is like on our TV shows or hosting our
TV show so it's really you know probably
the same thing but I heard a lot of
comics love it they really it's like a
really you know good place for comedy so
maybe that's the way to go I don't know
do you like what I get this all the time
but like where the best crowds like
what's your favorite city I hate that
question but I feel like you might have
a good answer to it I don't know I seem
to do really well in DC and I think
that's both smart you get like the
people of Virginia and you also get the
DC people so it's like a good mix San
Francisco that area still has like a
good kick to it like when you get out of
the IT world you know and like the real
that used to be like a real like
incubator of great comics you know so I
still always have like a soft spot for
SF in that area but I would say you know
anywhere where I can actually get like a
crowd like hilarities in Cleveland I
always do really well there and they're
usually a really cool crowd no not as
much moaning and groaning I'd say that
New York and LA are the most sensitive
of the town so you know it's tough to
like work on new material here but I
don't really don't know I think it's
like a combination of just like a lot of
people were working all day long and
it's hard for them to turn off their
filter yeah
to really like get it but then there's
people who come from all over the
country and they want to hear like New
York Comedy so
it's kind of a hard balance what do you
guys think I think la it's just mean we
were the Laugh Factory yeah that was a
good show though you killed it that was
it was a good show but it was like it's
we were talking about it's like there is
no audience like that anywhere else it's
right there pretty spoil because they do
get a lot of celebs like if you go to
the comedy store like within you know
two hours you'll see like five great
comment yeah they are spoiled that's a
good point but I always say about New
York it's like you're you become a
better comic here not just because of
the stage time but because you have to
follow and I always give your name you
have to follow people like Dave Attell
and you watch him and you're like well I
gotta step it up whereas in LA you're
following like really famous good
comedians but people are a little bit
more just like phoning it in just kind
of messing up they're not there they're
not bringing it as hard as New York
comics in here you just have to you know
I can't unless I try super hard I'm not
gonna be able to follow Dave Attell in
any way and so it forces you become
better yeah but you're killing it and
like in New York in New York the good
thing about it is like it starts so much
later whereas in LA which is what I hate
the most it's like hey we got you some
spots tonight what time it's like okay
we got an 8:30 I'm like 8:30 late spot I
love it like later so you can do like
everything else and get her sleep in
early yeah you're always you always
close out the shows this I'm like how
does he I don't I don't close them out
anymore I'm lucky I don't have to do
that anymore
well you do you come pretty late though
and but deep yeah I like to I like to do
like The Late Show but that used to be
the coolest show now I'd say that's just
like you really do get like it's a grab
bag you never know what what is a good
show anymore like who's gonna be the
crowd that kicks it I know it is all
over the place but there's so many rooms
there now at the cellar that black I
love yeah that's great and then the
Village Underground it's like I love
that that can be so hot too here's a
town that I'm sure you've played but
there really is no club as New Orleans
yeah play there yeah I've done like a
rock venue that would never no Club well
there's no club there's just too much
other and let's not dance around it
voodoo I'm sure there's some kind of
weird yeah
interview with a vampire kind of ever
have a laugh house yeah no there's just
too many other things going on but that
would be a cool place to go like when I
played the Comedy Cellar in Vegas that
was cool I was like that's great that
they have a venue here because this was
another place where unless you could
sell out like 2,000 seats or you work
with the tiger like there was no like
there's no in-between in Vegas you know
really it was just like either like
horribly sad comedy or like big Dave
yeah how do you keep track of all your
jokes
yeah like what you have so many and
there's so many that I bring up to you
all the time I was like that one do you
ever do that here we go I haven't
thought like do you do you do you write
them all down like where do you have
notebooks do you have in your phone well
I have two people that work with me one
handles my jokes the other one handles
my zingers no I I used to do the
notebook like everybody else
sorry and then I I still tape every show
but I can I cannot honestly say I listen
to every show and that is really the
most painful thing to do is to listen to
your horrible jokes doing horribly in a
place somewhere you don't even remember
you're like what where was that
you know and that's that to me it's like
the real work of comedy is listening to
your tape but yeah I like have I don't
do the notebook saying where I write
them down but really it's more about
like you know when I look at my work on
sheet which is like these are jokes that
have not been working for years I look
at them and it's like oh man I can't
believe I still haven't gotten a vitamin
Joe you know and then like when I get
one I'll use it and then I'll stop work
working and has to go back on the work
on yep so that sucks
yeah the what the work on she I don't
even have that actual sheet but we talk
about it all the time it's the joke you
do onstage and you go oh that's been a
placeholder that punchline has been a
placeholder for six years and I've
always been like think of something more
specific and better and you just never
do and it's always just a see yep cuz
like in your brain that is like now the
stop of that thought and like it's
really hard to like to take it out of
there and sometimes look like you're
like oh maybe if the joke bombs if I can
make it bomb and then then that'll
activate something else in my head yeah
but I noticed what the younger crowds
now like they're kind of joke averse
like if it's to joking for them they get
all whatever but if it's to like you
know like raw they get all
like nervous and all that stuff so it's
kind of like this fine line but I will
say one thing is that I'm in LA like
tags don't bring them you know like like
for some reason I hit like three shells
where I was like doing tags on jokes and
they're like we already laughed at your
joke dude just probably me
no that's that's probably a thing I
think you're so right though about they
want something in between of like setup
punch like something that they've seen
they don't like to see the work in it
they don't want you to just essentially
to tweet but if you share something too
raw there's been times where I'm like
something happened yesterday and it
literally yesterday you know we always
say yesterday but yesterday and they can
sense that it was like they're like we
can smell the jizz on you look like you
know what I mean like I showered since
that Joe yeah and they're grossed out
and they I'm always do you guys want me
to give you more distance from that and
say it was last week as opposed to raw
that you're right they like kind of
recoil it doesn't even have to be like
like salacious stuff could just be like
you know just something like
inappropriate and no and they like I can
just feel them pulling away but yeah
what are you guys thinking sometimes I
feel like they'll recognize that maybe
I'm too angry if it's a funny it just
sounds like you're just bitter
yeah it really tricks that I've found if
you just like like laughing at your own
jokes I know it's like the most
repulsive thing to watch a comic like
enjoy their own set but like it really
does trick audiences anymore it's such a
trick until now any other game
you
[Music]